who exhaled the loudest when Game of
Thrones was called as the winner tonight
I felt it felt right not relieved you
know the next day I think we deserved it
really over the course of everything so
dates about the final season although it
was rock and roll I love you you were
you were good with it cuz there was you
know there was a lot of talk about
what's going on do we do we love it do
we want more is it too short like what
happened no I was 100% fine with it yeah
from from the from the reading of the
scripts to how we made it manifest yeah
everything about our always wonderful
you have to remember them when people
waited as long as they had and they had
emotionally invested in this show I mean
there were the audience and everybody
involved in it we're joined at the hip
on this journey yeah and it's very
difficult when people love something
that for six weeks during we were
showing us we were saying goodbye and at
the end of it there was a lot of people
deeply unhappy that we took a beautiful
thing away from them I think you're
right I mean what is it like though to
be a part of television that changes the
face of you know a show that changes the
face of television pretty cool I think
we always knew from day one we were all
in something special it's been said many
times but there weren't any [ __ ]
so [ __ ] quotient from everybody
wasn't rated now there's gonna be a
prequel and Naomi Watts is gonna
headline this but do tell I know nothing
apart from we hope they have a tenth of
the time that we have doing our journey
and
[Music]
I see you guys I'm it this is a family
you guys like family he's the older
brother I'm the young one Kenny Rogers
Jr you do have a bit of that Kenny
Rogers going islands in the stream what
was your favorite part besides here in
Game of Thrones being announced as the
winner for Best Drama what was your
favorite part about the show tonight I
better show tonight it was one to know I
thought the no host element through a
you know brought variety to the whole
even you liked it I did announcer guy
the one that came up in a scrimmage do
you like him cuz there was a lot of
great youth I was a little taken aback
by him totally sort of camera on wrong I
did go oh so no host and you like the
announcer yeah yeah he was going to
everyone equally like Jesus I was asking
folks early but what is life like after
Game of Thrones empty shallow and
there's no real reason to go on actually
retired you know go in there raise a
glass to all your friends and family
today you guys deserve it thank you all
you
[Music]